run
[Music]
check check whoa
hello
everybody my name is Markiplier and
welcome to
I've recently opened my restaurant it
has been successful but for several
years I've had no competition
welcome to the
and they say that this competition makes
better hamburgers before I decided to
infiltrate the restaurant at night and
steal a secret recipe
welcome to the uh uh McDonald's horror
game
[Applause]
oh
what
uh sensibility I don't think that's the
right word yeah
I don't know about this one gang
relives left
this is some granny
G get the secret recipe what am I
am I looking for the recipe for the
Krabby Patty hideouts are used to hide
from the enemy you can get out of hiding
with the q key
why did you know I can get out of hiding
with the cube
what are you doing in there
Ronnie
what are you doing in there Ronnie
Ronaldo yeah I don't know what the deal
is with this game I didn't read a lot
I never looked in too much before I go
into a game but um
what do they have a vending machine
I couldn't possibly interact
oh Ronald
or there's an invisible wall
oh hi
well everyone's got a poop I guess
[Music]
um
wow alt plus what
plus F4
I
oh so you really are just patrolling in
there also going in while you're right
there would be a problem wouldn't it
weird all right I think it's my it's my
chance
won't that Ford open you know somehow I
doubt that phew
so this needs a key this is a mystery oh
there's a group oh
he might come in here but I'm assuming I
can just walk him in the back of the
head
with a crowbar
and that'll probably be fine
all right this is slightly concerning Oh
wrong time
oh god oh hey whoa hey I'm standing on
the poop toilet but yeah okay
you didn't hear that did you
far too stupid where did you go
where did you go
I'm hoping that he just went into the
kitchen and then
gonna go around because I'm about to
find myself a secret recipe
there but
I'm gonna walk around the corner and
he's gonna be right there just like it's
been before whoa oh no you don't
oh
okay uh
uh ow
hey wait a minute
did you hit my pressure oh God why does
the camera have to be even worse
well this doesn't make for a very
pleasant gaming experience I just gotta
say that
uh my brain okay so where did you go
oh God this is nion unplayable so this
is some granny
are you in here
way wow okay you're not gonna chase me
into the parking lot are you oh you
might oh you might hey
hey hey watch yourself man I wish I
could see yeah okay okay all right
there's no need there is no need
I don't know why you did you rip the
door off this clothes
hide I'll do that you'll never know
don't do it
oh well
okay all right well I hope my vision
isn't even more blurry because that
would be really really
uh is there any way to get rid of it no
sensibility is it
gonna increase myself oh you know what
I'm not gonna make people go through
that I'm gonna get this on a first try
basis or I'm not gonna get it at all
that's just that's just how this is
gonna go because I'm I'm not gonna deal
with the nausea of that this is bad
enough but anything else is just
unacceptable where you at buddy
I'm going for it
to get the criber
whoa
because if I close this I can definitely
hear what he comes in
I can't close that but I can stay here
how did I lose him before
he was on to me and then he suddenly
wasn't onto me
I don't know
there he is
so as soon as he leaves which I don't
really know the metric by which he would
leave
sliver of him leaving there
so as soon as he leaves I'm going to
follow behind and then I'm going to get
under the desk that is adjacent to there
he goes
follow behind
very carefully
oh
okay so he's he might he might I don't
know if he will for sure okay he did
okay
so he went back that way
McDonald's
did you do that
[Music]
nice pants okay so he's going back there
which is my opportunity to go over here
and then I can go here and get that and
open this why what why
I feel like this should insert your
happy meal
I don't have a Happy Meal
what
hey
Ron
did he leave
okay so maybe I
okay all right so I need wait
maybe I oh there we go you're not coming
are you good no one Minds a floor onion
do they
oh God
okay so there's one other ingredient
that I'm missing apparently Patty needs
another Patty
oh
this is my chance
can I go now God
I don't know what that noise was maybe I
need a box
why is he not coming in here I'm not
leaving until he comes in here cause I'm
not gonna I'm not about to be caught
with my pants down so he's gonna be
coming in here any minute now and then
I'm gonna go and get up
your happy meal like something like that
I don't know I think I need to put a
Happy Meal there and then the door will
magically open even though I already
pulled the boards off of him if you got
some magical thing that can detect when
a Happy Meal is there and not when the
boards are ripped off why do you even
have the boards on in the first place it
doesn't make any sense like I'm all for
redundancy but that's just a little too
redundant
all right I know this is just gonna be a
thing where as soon as I step out here
I'll walk right in oh no he's not we're
oh oh oh God
what is he doing
what are you doing you weirdo he's just
standing there
oh
all right whatever I don't know what I'm
supposed to do okay this needs that this
needs that
uh the secret recipe is right there so
what
why do you keep faking me out like that
okay so they're in the bathroom for some
reason there was a there's a door with a
key in it though or the door the lock on
it the needs a key so there's got to be
a key somewhere I thought he came in
here
I was almost positive that's what
occurred but apparently not
okay so is there anything else
oh that
anything else in here
bud
what are you doing over there bud
whoa
Sophie doesn't actually come in here I'm
pretty safe
because he just weirdly stands by the
door and not at the oh he doesn't even
go to the door so where's a key oh
wait a minute
ooh that might be it
so if I grab you won't mind if I steal
this do you
oh well God why did it okay eat Ron
ah just for good measure
I stole your and now you're dead
what
ah
what ending two of three all right okay
um
all right I guess I gotta know hang on I
gotta I gotta figure out what the um
I know it's probably just trolling me
but there's a door
that says Alta four and I don't know if
that's
a hundred percent accurate but
if you think about it
so that needs a key
what is Ronald doing in that art over
there I don't even know is that like a
secret message a secret
one turd one burger bun sliced pickle
Secret Sauce oh God
I don't want to make that I don't want
to make that at all oh God
oh
uh
all right well it doesn't seem to be a
possibility right now so I don't know
why he's giving me
shut
I'm gonna try it alter four
I know it's a I know it's a troll
I know it's a troll but just in case
just in case they did something that was
like oh oh man you gotta oh it's trip
some secret code
oh I don't know oh do I gotta go oh God
I gotta go through the whole intro story
oh come on
all right let's try this again what a
silly game but honestly sometimes you
need silly games
unless people think that this is an
unbelievably serious game and
treated with the utmost respect which
maybe maybe it's true
maybe you do there's gotta be something
there with that sign
and how it's like all telling all this
secret oh you need the secret
turd burger
no no well I thought you would be
that didn't work
stupid well maybe there is something
with the turd burger I don't know why
but it's there and it makes sense so all
things considered oh
Ron
run run
Ronald
Ron Ron
Ron
oh my God
what what
what happened I don't know what happened
that was weird
okay all right Ron where are you okay
you're in the bathroom right now
I really want to know about that turd
burger
oh God
never you wouldn't don't even think
about it idiot so
one turd burger bun
sliced pickles Secret Sauce there's a it
sure to intricately model a turd in the
toilet here I can't imagine that that
oh hey okay all right I
man is this worth it is it worth it to
explore the intricacies and secrets that
a lie in the heart of whatever this is I
don't know where did I get the
explosives how did I blow this up where
did I resort to domestic terrorism when
did that when did I go through that
Crossroads in my life maybe it's a troll
maybe there aren't actually three
endings I don't see how there could be
because I don't know what else I'm
supposed to do
there couldn't possibly be anything else
to do the turd burger has to be a troll
it has to be oh well I'm in trouble
aren't I
Ron
Ron Ron gone
wrong gone
where did Ron go
he does that sometime when he tries to
go into the bathroom I think he warps
into another dimension and just like
loses himself for a little bit until the
game respawns and back in
because there's no way he's gone
unless he is there's no way
oh there he he was outside how did you
get outside
what happens if I close you in there
whoa
there's a secret recipe in there is
there anything else in there what is
that over on the right
there's something floating on the right
over there
[Music]
so what is this floating off to the
right
I don't want to blow up the McDonald's
I guess the only other ending that I can
think of is if I get caught three times
let me just see what that is unless
there is some unbelievable secret turd
burger ending which I don't even know
how would you do that
I'm gonna take this somewhere else
this needs to Keith there's got to be a
key there so I'm just gonna take the
death ending ow
all right seizure warning everybody so I
don't know why I spawn in my car every
time Ron do you have a key on your
person are you
[Music]
person or you how did you know
how did you know uh
wait there's a trash can there's got to
be something to do with the trash can as
well but let me just go ahead and die so
that I can move on let me bite the big
one and then how do you know how do you
know
well I like guy and
all right what what what do you have a
gun what are you doing oh you you ah
looker made
what what
I don't know okay let me try the Crowbar
on the trash can because maybe that's
something that I'm
figuring it
maybe that's a secret maybe there's a
key in the trash can something like that
duck outside
see if I can pry open the trash can
no
well it's interactable
but what am I supposed to interact
what do you interact on it maybe I throw
away the Happy Meal I don't know out
piss him off
maybe I get a drink
why are those lighting up
oh
God
you don't come in here oh maybe he looks
at it when I when I break down the
boards he's like oh
throw away a Happy Meal how do you feel
about that what about the drink machine
is there something like that nope all
right I'm out of here don't turn around
okay
I don't know I don't know of anything
else that would be interactable here I
don't know of anywhere else that there
would be a key hidden I don't know of
anything about anything
trash trash
nope nope nope
I don't know
maybe I just wonk them
maybe that's what I need to do maybe I
just need to go up in the back of his
head and wonk him good
surprise run yeah okay well that was
awkward I'll just give you a nice hug
from behind listen Bud Budd you don't
need to do this bud bud
bet you can't find me through a
Lamppost oh God oh my God all right well
you never catch up with me at a moderate
leisurely pace
actually he wouldn't surprisingly
oh hi
privacy
all right okay well I can't possibly
figure this out and you know what I
don't really want to it's not that the
game's bad or anything it's just like uh
I don't think it leads me to pursue the
deeper mysteries of this universe it's
just one of those things where when you
leave your mind to imagine the horrors
that could be there it just fills in the
gaps in such a more beautiful way so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out more scary games that I played
through Link in the description below
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]